let's jump to the story from the Daily
Caller quote we are already in a civil
war Billy Porter sounds off on
anti-transgender legislation across the
country
this is uh an actor who appeared on The
View
and he said we're already in a civil war
it's a civil war of the mind they're
trying to take your mind and I felt like
that was him desperately trying to walk
things back and it's because you have
politicians around the country in these
states banning the uh genital removal
amputation of children by doctors under
the guise of gender of affirmation
what I found interesting with this story
it was just what two weeks ago that Jane
Fonda called for murder of pro-lifers on
The View
so let me just ask you guys The View
prominent morning talk show with
millions of Watchers on network
television runs an episode where some
where a prominent personality says we
need the right to abortion
gets asked okay well aside from voting
and protesting what can you do she says
murder and then they laugh and what
would you say she said murder and
they're like she's joking everyone she's
joking and then a week or two later a
guy comes on and says we're already in a
civil war
this is mainstream corporate Network
television advocating for murder and
saying we're in a civil war
at what point you know I I feel like
everyone thinks that a house fire starts
by you sitting in a room then boom the
house just in Flames every single room's
on fire you're like whoa my house is on
fire like they don't realize that it
could be a tiny little kindling on your
curtains and you can watch it for five
minutes it slowly grows and then 10
minutes and then 20 minutes and now the
Wall's on fire and now it's run away and
then and then 10 20 minutes later now
half your building gets consumed because
exponential growth
when we're watching Network television
advocate for murdering people for being
pro-life but haha just a joke and then
later you get a guy coming out being
like we're already in a civil war
at what point does someone just say you
know the house is on fire
it we're in it it's been a couple years
has been violence it's on fire
oh I'll say it the house is on fire it
is it is me it is it's kind of burning
down we're at that it's not just like a
kindling it's not just the wall we're at
that point where we are close to having
no United place for everybody to live
under the same roof and we desperately
need people to put down the Flames if we
want to be able to maintain that the
question is do we want to maintain that
do we want to live together you know
I'll tell Billy this my wife and I have
proudly been a part of legislation we
helped get passed in Tennessee to ban
these transgender surgeries their sex
changes it's mutilation of somebody's
genitals and to ban the hormone
treatments for kids and puberty blockers
so basically the law essentially is you
have to wait till you're 18 to make
decisions okay
um I don't think that's too wild I think
honestly if it was my personal opinion
injected into it people would wait a lot
longer or never have it done because I
think that there's an underlying cause
it really needs to be seen But in
Billy's case I will say this
he loves to wear dresses and I just have
a general rule I have two rules one is I
I don't ever answer emails from people
who put pronouns in their thing I don't
care if they're offering me a million
dollars I'm not answering them the other
one is I don't take advice or take
seriously men who wear dresses Billy
loves to wear dresses so I'm just going
to disregard what he says but in terms
of what you said on the Civil War Front
we're we're at that point where they
have they have lit the fire I'm wearing
jeans
what about women wearing jeans they're
cool right they're cool yeah but you put
a dress on I am out and no actually
we'll put up a wall I had a similar
thought it wasn't that I didn't know he
wore dresses but I I don't know who this
guy is so I don't I'm not going to take
him seriously I mean a lot of people
have a lot of opinions about us being at
War about the world ending about horror
and Trauma and like I don't give a
it's not it's it's not you have some
sort of established the view it's them
on The View with him going yeah
by the way when they said she was joking
she said had her face going no I'm not
and she looks around like well well no
I'm not yeah and by the way can we pull
up pictures of them I don't know I'm not
like in control of this show but if we
can pull up pictures of his dress I
would like to remind people if I mean a
picture of him in his dresses that this
is what the left hip this is what they
have on is an intellectual okay that
they take seriously but like this and
that's and look I don't care the issue
is their world view is so different
there is no point at which we bring them
together everyone I'm I'm look the last
thing we want is National divorce China
would take over the world yeah well it's
already happening they've got to deal
with Russia the brics nations are
talking about working with with the
Saudis you've got Saudi Saudi Arabia
they're going to be trading oil and Juan
we are losing it's happening because we
have you know what man we've been
defeated put it simply China dude we are
very close mentality is the defeat we're
on we we have a country run by a family
that is doing deals with China I'm
they're not running it though it's a
banking establishment it's running sure
and China's winning and the Petro dollar
is failing and and uh for For Better or
For Worse America's standing is the
unipolar power is done you could say
winning but I don't think it's done I
don't think it's over I mean yes
or the US Empire is done the liberal
economic order it's really the British
Empire but yeah the U.S economically I
think I think the United States will
exist it will continue but what I see
happening right now is Tick Tock for
instance Chinese company and it's
telling our kids you're getting that
dude who's saying who's who's he does
those videos where he's like leave your
parents Jeffrey Marsh yeah and he's like
I created a patreon so that you can send
messages to me privately you know what I
mean and you people like Dylan Mulvaney
we went over Dylan Mulvaney's Tick Tock
and it's sad because when he started
making content he was it's clear he was
trying to figure out what would get him
views animal content talking about
Broadway LGBT content and then he made a
non-binary video million views then he
comes at his Trends three million views
and from there he's getting Millions
upon millions of views it's obvious all
he wanted in my opinion at least was the
attention in China Tick Tock is science
and education so what I mean to say is
when we've been defeated is that the
people who believe in America the people
who want America to be strong are being
fought from within by people who have no
principles no morals and just want to
win nothing apparently they want to
castrate children they want to sterilize
children they want to abort their kids
they want the government to spend money
in uh indefinitely into Oblivion for
hyper to generating hyperinflation aoc's
advocated for deficit spending health
care which would just destroy the
economy overnight and we are fighting
with them instead of China who's
engaging in the Belt Road initiative
who's doing oil exploration for decades
now in Africa and South America so I
should say this it's not over yet fine
fair point but China is doing all these
things now they do have economic
problems it's not like we're doing we're
in doing nothing but China and Russia do
a deal China is doing oil deals of Saudi
Arabia what I'm saying is that Domino
has been flicked over to end the Petro
dollar and a unipolar world led by the
United States and it's because our
leaders are people like Joe Biden Donald
Trump could first this and Donald Trump
was doing it in the right way securing
our borders bringing back jobs the
economy was booming that's the right way
to save America Joe Biden is flying on
Air Force two with his son to negotiate
private Equity deals while working for
the US government and then getting his
brother oh let me slow down while
overseeing the Iraqi Invasion the Iraqi
Invasion his brother happens to get
lucrative construction contracts I'll
put it that way or flying to Ukraine and
engaging in an illegal quid pro quo to
get a prosecutor fired who just so
happened to be investigating a company
his son was on the board of that's what
we have in leadership right now so if
China is expanding rapidly and doing
these deals to subvert the United States
and internally we're just fighting each
other that's why I say we've been
defeated yeah that would be the end if
we just fight each other as the ship
sinks and here's the point Billy Porter
goes on The View and says children
should have their testicles removed
surgically why won't Republicans let us
do this and to me in my world view I'm
like are you people insane there is no
logical reason let me phrase it this way
let's take a logical assessment of what
they call gender affirming care a person
comes to me and says that they will harm
themselves and their own life unless a
doctor surgically removes their hand do
you know what we would do to that person
it's called a 5150 they get placed on a
temporary psychiatric hold to make sure
they don't harm themselves Amanda Bynes
was walking around Los Angeles naked and
she got put on a 5150 and she wasn't
hurting anybody she was just naked then
you get these people who come out and
they've been saying it for years if we
don't amputate the genitals of these
children they'll kill themselves and I'm
like well I don't care if they're kids
or adults anybody who threatens that you
put them on a psychiatric hold to make
sure they don't hurt themselves don't
amputate their body parts that was the
number one argument against the bill we
got passed in Tennessee was we had these
people come in and say basically you
guys want to kill children and we're
like okay first of all that is insane
but secondly what other thing do we
operate under this assumption where we
say oh we're going to let patients
dictate care as long as they go and
threaten us with suicide and what are we
teaching kids about the future are we
teaching these kids that if they have a
let's say boyfriend or girlfriend who
threatens to commit suicide that they
need to do whatever that person says and
stay with them to prevent their suicide
because suddenly you're responsible for
the bad behavior or bad actions of other
people and what do we do if it's a kid
with anorexia Because by the way
anorexia has a higher suicide rate than
these kids who say they're trans and so
do we say you know what kids with
anorexia we're going to go ahead and
give you liposuction we'll give you lap
band because that's suddenly going to
make everything better if we mutilate
you further and destroy your mind
further that's going to suddenly
possibly make a couple of you happy
no we would never do that we understand
how damaging that could be and so we
have a responsibility as adults to tune
out threats no good parent listens to
their kid throw a tantrum and goes I'm
going to give in now because you
threatened some do and and this is the
point that I've said good parents right
some parents do it's I've explained the
woke stuff as the mother in the ice
cream shop and the kids screaming I want
the mother's going okay please just
please stop yelling oh you're yelling in
my ear oh please give him ice cream I
had a personal experience where I dated
a girl that was suicidal and I tried to
be there for her you can't at least from
my experience it didn't it wasn't
effective it couldn't stop it she tried
to kill herself there's nothing I could
do about it I just had to live my life
and it was like of course me going and
living my life was the day she did it
but that doesn't mean that it wouldn't
have happened if I just sat there crying
in the room next to her waiting for her
to figure it out one day like you can't
man and it's not your fault if they do
that all you can do is love people give
them the tools and sometimes loving them
means doing hard things and things they
may not like you know and I think that's
the truth of it and I think what Tim
said is absolutely true if you have a
child who's genuinely threatening to
commit suicide if you don't chop off
their genitals you need to get them
psychiatric here and you need to get it
to them
instead they're affirming all of it like
if body dysmorphia is a real thing I
brought it up on the on the Rogan
podcast with Dorsey and Vegeta uh
because I I did I've done the research
on it I'm like there are people who will
stage accidents to get body parts
amputated there was one story I read
about a guy who cut a tree down and then
as it was falling he put his arm under
it so that it would crush his arm to
force an amputation because he wanted
his arm removed and the doctors would
not do it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time